これから
いわゆる完璧主義という言葉をテーマにして
お釈迦様が我々に何をおっしゃいましたか
ということについてお話をさせていただきます
いくらかお釈迦様
我々に言おうと
おっしゃろうとしているところは
この説明書の文章の中にも入ってあっただろうと思います
ですから
あまり難しく私に喋ることはそれほどはないんです
大体どんな人間でも
心の中では完璧になりたいとかね
完全にやることは完全にしたいという気持ちはあるんですよ
ない人はほとんどないぐらい
それでたまたまいるんですね
何一つも完璧に正しくしようとしないで
する人々もいますよ
何やっても中途半端で
途中でやめたり
あるいは物事も変えて違うことをしてしまったり
どちらでも何者かとわからないぐらいの
性格の人もいますけどね
仕事をしたとしても
ゴロゴロ変わったりするし
勉強にしても
こういうことをちょっとやったり
他のことをちょっとやったりとか
結局最終的には何も得てないという
そういう人もいるんだけど
それは大勢じゃないんですよ
数少ないんですね
ですから
そういう何人かがね
大体どんな社会でも
大体 100人
200人ぐらい人々を調べると
1人ぐらいはそうやってこの中途半端な生き方で
生きている人々もいますけど
他の方々は真面目に普通に生活したい方々っていうのは
大勢の人々なんですね
そういう方々は大体
やることはしっかりやりたいと
しっかりなさりたいという気持ちはあるんです
それは一般的で普通なんですよ
しっかりやりたくないと思うならば
それはちょっとした病気みたいなもので
数少ない人々だから
それほど我々気にしなくてもいいんです
そこで問題は
そういう問題児のことではなくて
我々のことなんですよ
完璧　完全主義を持っている我々のことなんですね
だからどういうことかというと
物事を完全にうまく成功したいんですが
なかなかうまくいかない
いろいろトラブルが起きたりする
問題も起きたりする
そういう一般的な真面目な方々の間の問題なんですね
今日のタイトルは
完璧主義という言葉がね
この説明の章にあったように
良い面も悪い面も見ようとすれば見られます
大体　これから悪い面だけで考えていますけど
物事を完璧にしようしようと
思っているところでうまくいかないと
かなりストレスになっちゃうんですよ
かなり自己嫌悪になっちゃうんですね
悔しくなっちゃうんですね
それで自信がなくなってしまっちゃうんですよ
あまりにも失敗すると
そうするとそれはいいことではありません
完璧に何かしようとしたところで失敗しましたと
また頑張ったところでまた失敗しましたと
そういうことで自信がなくなってしまって
もうやる気がなくなってしまって
さらに問題が起きたりする
暗くなってしまっちゃう
そういうとこは
我々はいくらか考えてみましょう
ある法句経でお釈迦様はこういう偈がおっしゃいましたけど
Na cāhu na ca bhavissati, na cetarahi vijjati
Ekantaṃ nindito poso
ekantaṃ vā pasaṃsito
今日は書くことはちょっとできませんですけど
Na cāhu　いたこともない
na ca bhavissati
これからもいるわけではありません
na cetarahi vijjati
今もいませんと
誰ですか？
Ekantaṃ nindito poso
極端に非難するべき人
完全に悪いだと
非難するべき人っていうのは昔もいなかったし
これからも現れないし
今もいませんと
もう一つ
ekantaṃ vā pasaṃsito
完全に素晴らしいんだと
完璧だと褒めるべき
極端に褒めるべき人もいませんと
だからその中にお釈迦様の言葉の中に
ちゃんと全てまとめてあると思いますね
昔もいなかった
今もいない
これからも現れようともしない
どういう人かというと
極端に悪い人だという極悪人もいませんし
もう完璧に素晴らしい人だという完全な人もいませんと
ということで
お釈迦様は何をおっしゃいますかというと
人間というのは誰でもそこそこ
いるんだということなんですよ
誰一人も完璧ではありませんと
だからといってダメだと
極悪人だと
ゴミだと
何の役にも立たないんだと思って
人を捨てることもできませんと
そういう人はいませんと
極端な人が
いるのはみんな真ん中なんですよ
だから前申し上げた
この中途半端なろくに仕事もしないで
ゴロゴロ仕事を変わったり
いろんなことをやっている人々にしても
もうちゃんと叱って指導すれば
強引にでもね
なんとか人生は明るくすることはできるんだからね
ですから
両極端には人間はいませんということは
まず理解してほしい
その4行のお釈迦様の言葉を理解してもらうと
正しく理解してもらうと
我々に何が役に立ちますかと
我々には
まず私が申し上げたいのは
落ち着くことができるんですよ
みんな不完全だよと
みんなそこそこだよと
そういうお釈迦様の言葉っていうのは
石に彫るような感じで心に彫ってもらいたいんですよ
決して忘れてはいけないんですよ
すぐ忘れちゃうんですよ
すぐ忘れて
大体自分のことを棚上げにして
他人から完璧なことを認めようとする
要求する
他人がちょっとでもミスを犯しちゃったら
それは全然認めない
こちらはすごく苛立ちを感じる
怒ったり怒鳴ったりする
非難したりする
そこで心の平和が消えてしまっちゃいますよ
心の平和が消えてしまうだけではなくて
その二人の人間関係も
ものすごくややこしくなるんです
それで我々はさらに失敗するように
なってしまっちゃうんです
だからすごい単純な論理なんですよ
お釈迦様がおっしゃったことは
頭の上辺だけ
ああ　なるほど
そういえばその通りだと
完全な人はもういませんと
お釈迦様に言ってもらわなくても
それぐらいのこと知ってるんだと
いうふうに気取っちゃいますけど
でも知ってるんだとか
知ったかぶりで気取ってもらっても
役には立ちません
自分の人生
幸せにはしてくれません
ですから
お釈迦様の言葉なんかは
私が知ってるぞと旗を上げて
世の中に見せるためではなくて
本当に心の中に彫ってほしいんですよ
きちんと消えないように刷った方がいいんですよ
常に自分のこの何といいますか
よりどころ
自分のマニュアル
何かあったらすぐ参照するっていうような感じで
心のマニュアルになってないと役に立ちません
ですから
その 4行で言ったことは大変簡単単純なことでしょう
別に難しい論理あるわけじゃないんです
昔もいなかった
過去も将来も現れません
完璧な人が今もいませんと
ですから
今我々にとっては今だけ大事でしょうし
ですから今我々一緒に生活している仲間が
みんないろいろそこそこの人々やと
いいところもあって
悪いところもあるんだと
それは理解するだけなんですよ
それだけ理解すると
人の悪口
隠れてコソコソと言うこともなくなっちゃうし
言う必要ないんですよ
完全な人はいませんから
何か失敗したとしても
それにものすごい神経質になって
ヒステリーを起こして怒鳴ったりする
必要もないんですね
あるいは何回言っても聞いてくれないと
もう諦めてしまって
この人はもう役に立ちませんと
なんで私は不幸でしょうかと
そういうふうに暗く考える必要はないんです
だから必要なのは
心の大きさと同時に謙虚であること
私が完璧ではないんだと
どうせいろいろ失敗するんだと
いくら注意したとしても
気がつかないところでいろんなことを
失敗したりはするんだと
ですから
大きな顔は出せませんと
同時に他の人も何か失敗したら
そこら辺はもう理解をすること
できるようになるんですね
そういうことで
今日のテーマには結論がはっきり決まってるんですよ
ずっと研究して出す必要ないんです
不完全です
人間は 体も不完全で
心も不完全なんですよ
だから不完全な機械を持って
完璧というところにチャレンジしても
結局骨が折れるだけなんですよ
さらに不幸になるだけで終わってしまっちゃいますね
だから結論ははっきりしているんです
それで時々お釈迦様の教えっていうのは
なんかどうも暗いんじゃないかなと
ちょっと批判的ではないかなと
お釈迦様はそれほどきつく批判しなかったんだけど
それにも付け加えた私の言葉の使い方は
えらいもう激しいんだから
さらにもう暗く聞こえるかもしれません
今日はいくらか落ち着こうかなと
一応努力はしているんだけど
途中でどうなるかわかりませんよ
いきなりまた普通の調子に戻るかもしれません
座ってるんだからいくらか安心ですけど
立ってしゃべるとわからなくなっちゃうんです
お釈迦様の教えはそういうことで
なんとか暗いんではないかと
それ暗いんじゃないんですよ
それは人々の取り方が間違っているだけであって
お釈迦様は我々には心の安らぎを教えてるんですよ
こんなヒステリーになるなよと
子どもが勉強できないんだと
だからそんなお母さんヒステリーになる必要ないんだと
落ち着きなさいよと
それでも自分の子どもでしょうと
だからかわいがってあげてよと
助けてあげてよと
面倒を見てあげなさいよと
勉強する
ちょっとできなくても
あるいは子供はいつでもどこへ行っても喧嘩するんだと
ああ　困った困ったと
それに必死になって胃潰瘍になったりしてね
病院まで行くようになるどころではないんですよ
そんなことで
だからお釈迦様はすごく簡単にすぐ結果を得られる
修行の結果として幸せになるんじゃなくて
ただ理解しただけで心がそれなりに結果が得られる
すごい特効薬なんですね
教えているのは特効薬というんで
その場合は瞬時に効く薬なんて言います
特効薬 お釈迦様の教えは特効薬なんですよ
それからそのお釈迦の教えっていうのは
全部狙い撃ちなんですよ
中途半端で回って
どちらでも当たるところに
当たってくださいということじゃなくて
ちゃんと問題に狙って答えているんですよ
ですから特効薬であって
狙い撃ちの言葉であって
聞いたら理解した途端
それで幸せになるはずなんですよ
だから人間っていうのはいつでもなんか演じちゃうんですね
テキストなんか読んだら
ああ　なるほど
よくわかります
よく納得できますとかね
お釈迦様の初期経典でも今いっぱい日本訳ありますから
よく納得いきますとかね
あんな気取りはどうかなと私は思いますけどね
これを納得いった
よくわかったっていうことじゃなくて
本当に心の中にそれを刷り込まれたか
ないかっていうことなんですよ
何かあったらパッとあの言葉が思い浮かぶかないか
それがなければ
お釈迦様の幸せ
お釈迦様がおっしゃっりたかった幸せを
発見できないんですよ
だからお釈迦様は亡くなる時も法を島にしなさいと
よりどころにしなさいと
自己をよりどころにしなさいと
教えをよりどころにしなさいと
attadīpā　bhikkhave　viharatha
それから
dhammadīpā　bhikkhave　viharatha
attasaraṇā　anaññasaraṇā
他人に頼るなよと
dhammadīpā　bhikkhave　viharatha
dhammasaraṇā　真理に頼りなさい
anaññasaraṇā
他のものに頼ってはいけませんと
だから自分に頼る
それから真理に頼る
心の中に
自分の心の中に
この言葉を刷り込まれてもらう
そうすると
それを土台にして生きられる
生きていれば
それを島にして生きていればいいんです
それを導くようにして生きていればいいんです
決して悪いことにはなりません
これは100%の的中率がありまして
特効薬ですから
ですから我々この人間の社会で
いつでも人の過ちについて
人の失敗について
それから自分の過ちについて
自分の失敗について
いろんなトラブルを犯しているんですよ
特にグループで行動する場合は
もう大変ややこしいんですよ
なかなかうまくいかない
ちょっとしたしきたりでも間違ったら
すごい怒って帰る人もいるんですよ
ちょっと挨拶ちょっと間違ったら
ちょっと言葉遣い間違っただけでも
まあ腹が立って帰ること
そういうふうに帰るんだけど
じゃあその方が完璧かと
また逆に聞きたいんですけどね
だからいつでも自分の不完全性を置いといて
他人から完璧になってほしいと希望する
それもおかしいことは自分に対してなんですよ
自分に対して完璧に対応してくれと
そんなこと世の中でありきですかと
あるべきかと聞きたいぐらいのことなんですね
例えば私に挨拶間違ったら
私はもうカンカン怒ったりする
でも私がその人を他の人にものすごい丁寧に
正しく挨拶しているのは見てるんですね
見ていても
私はそれ　認めたくない
人のことはどうでもいいんです
彼が　その人が私に対して言葉が間違ったんだと
怒ったりするんですね
それで自分に対してはすごくいい顔をして
世の中に悪い顔をしても
自分がその人の肩を取る
私に対して悪いことしていないんだから
私は悪い人だと思いませんよと
そういう世界もありますね
自分のものは盗まないんだけど
人のものを盗むとわかっても
私はあの人を何も盗むと思いませんよと
平気で言ったりする
だから　自分に対して完璧であったらそれで十分だと
人に対してはどうでもいいんだという
この主義は間違いであって
その代わりにすべての人間がそれぞれ
そこそこ生きているんだと
不完全だと　ということは理解しておけば
心にすごく安らぎ
落ち着きというものは出てくる
自分に対しても落ち着くんですよ
自分が失敗したとしても
まあまあ
今度頑張るんだと
そういうふうに
次のことにチャレンジすればいいんです
それで次のポイントなんですけど
じゃあ不完全だから
どんな過ちも我々は認めるべきかという
放っておくんですか？
見て見ぬふりするんですかと
人の過ち
失敗を無視するべきですかという問題は次に来るんですね
だって不完全だからね
しょうがないんだからと
いいやと
そういうふうな態度をとっていいんでしょうかと
あるいは不完全なことを間違った失敗したところで
怒鳴りつけていいんですかと
それにはお釈迦様は大体どんな問題も答える場合は
vibhajjavādaという言葉を使っているんですよ
vibhajjavāda
vibhajjaっていうのは分析
テーラワーダ仏教のもう一つの名前があるんですよ
それはvibhajjavādaなんですよ
我々はすごく威張ってその言葉を使っているんです
theravada
theravadaとあまり使わない
使ってはいるんだけど
別に使わないんですよ
結局　何ワーダという何宗とかも使ってないんですから
仏教は一緒だと向こうは思っているんだから
外国なんかに行ったら
我々はどんな仏教かとなんとか言わなくちゃいけないんだから
theravadaというだけで
国へ帰っちゃったら何ワーダも言わないんです
一応歴史的に仏教は分裂しちゃったでしょうに
そこで分裂したところで
元の人々は自分たちのことをどのように言ったかというと
vibhajjavāda
アショーカ王様が　いろんな人々が
邪教の人々
違う宗教の人々も出家してごまかしやっていたんだから
みんなインタビューしたんですよ
インタビューして
お釈迦様は何主義者ですかと聞くんだそうです
聞いたんだそうです
聞いたらvibhajjavādaですよと言ったお坊さんたちを
あなた方は正しいお坊さんたち
仏教のお坊さんたち
弟子たちですよと
お釈迦様はこの主義だ
この主義だと言った人々は
あなた方は仏教をわかってない
違う教えを考えているんだから出ていってくださいと
分かれてしまったという
歴史には一応記録しているんです
ですから
お釈迦様の主義はvibhajjavādaという主義なんですね
だから
それ何なのかと
わからないです
vibhajjavāda　パーリ語言ったとしてもね
vibhajjaっていうのは
この分析するということなんです
分けて分けて分けて
切って切って切ってみるということ
英語の言葉で言えば
analytic analysismですよ
ちゃんと明確に分けてみる
まとめて大雑把で大胆で問題は見ようとしない
例えば一つの
例を申し上げます
最近　また一連の事件が起きてきたんですね
ほとんど子供たちが
事件を起こした
起こしたということがね
それ事件一つが出て
またつなげて
2つ目に 3番目
4番目出てくると
世の中の知識人たちが
ああ　大変だ
この国はどうなっているんですか？
今ごろの若者はどうなっているんですか？
今ごろの子供たちはどうなっているんでしょうかとかね
ああいうのは私から見ればいい加減な考え方で
今ごろの子供たちはどうなってもないんですよ
ただ　事件を起こしたのはただ
4つ　5つぐらいだけだから
どんな高校生も人殺したりバスジャックしたり
しないでしょうに
まとめにすごい真剣
真面目に頑張っている子供たちの方が多いでしょうに
親と喧嘩したり
家庭内暴力したりする子供の数がすごく少ないでしょうに
データ取ってみれば
それなのに一つの事件はものすごく大きくして
大雑把でいい加減で
喋って喋って
気が済んだら終わる
それでああいう問題を起こす子供たちの役には
一銭の役にも立たない
そこでもし問題の子供を抱えているお母さんにとっても
そういう話
いくら聞いたとしても
何一つも役に立ったことでなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから
物事っていうのは分析した方がいいんですよ
大雑把で見て
みんな同じ色で塗ってもらうと
そういう生き方は良くない
普通の方々は誰でも大体そういう生き方なんですね
そこら辺の外人でも誰かね
何か問題を起こしちゃったら
私も歩けなくなっちゃうんです
同じ目で見てしまうっていうのは
そういうのは大体普通やってますけど
お釈迦様のような仏弟子たちは
そうしてはいけないんだと
お兄ちゃんが殺人を起こしたんだからといって
弟も殺人者扱いするのは良くないんですよ
弟は弟で
ですから
お釈迦様が大体分析主義
なんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想をなさっている皆様も
知っているかもしれませんけど
かなり分析させちゃうんですよ
私という大雑把な概念を
きめ細かく
小さく小さく分けて分けて
最小単位に分けてみるんですね
どこに私がいるんですかと
そういうアプローチなんです
ですから
今私が出した問題にしても
同じアプローチなんですよ
もう忘れたと思いますから
また繰り返しますけど
やっぱり世の中の失敗過ちを
私たちは見て見ぬふりすべきですか？
あるいは怒鳴りつけて
それになんとかするべきかと
その時は分析的にアプローチ
した方がいいんですよ
こちらにも書いてありましたから
例えば外科医がいるとする
その人の仕事は人の体を切ること
切ることと縫うことと貼ることなんですよ
どうせ人間失敗するんだからね
車を運転したとしても
たまたま失敗するでしょうに
バックしたところでぶつかったとかね
カーブしたところでちょっと引っかかったとかは
大体たまたまあるかもしれませんから
じゃあ我々は外科医もまあまあそこそこ
頑張ってくださいと頼むべきかと
先生　失敗したんですか？
まあいいわ
いいわ 誰でも失敗するんだからと
例えば手術中
誰かとしゃべったところで
肺に行くべき血管は心臓の血管につなげたとか
そういう失敗は我々は認めるべきかというと
当たり前のことで
その場合は
その人は自分の仕事は完璧にやってほしいんです
人の命を預かっているんだから
かすかな失敗も医療ミスも認めてはいけませんでしょ
だから点滴だと思って石鹸を入れたケースもあったでしょうに
人の体に石鹸か中毒剤
消毒剤ですか
それで人が死んじゃったと
手術で患者さん入れ替えて間違ったとかね
そういう失敗はまあ認めるべきではありません
ということは常識で誰でも知っています
ですから
人の命を預かったところでは
100パーセント完璧であることは
認めなくてはならないんですよ
それで自分の子供は先月の試験では
95点取ったんだけど
今月はなんで60ですかと
それに子供をいじるべきですかと
その子供に我々は完璧
完璧ということを認めるべきですかと
それはどうってことないでしょうに
時々山手線でもたまにあるんだけど
ほんのちょっと行き過ぎになっちゃうんですね
駅で
それでまた何のことなく電車をバックして
停止位置に持ってくるんですよ
でも一応運転手たちっていうのはすごく訓練を受けてますよ
ぴったし停止位置に来てきちんと止まってくれるんですよ
全自動で動く電車は別としてね
大阪にもあります
東京にも1本ぐらいありますからね
完全無人電車が
完全無人電車は機械だから素晴らしくぴったし止まるんですよ
でも人間が操縦する場合はちょっとずれたりする
それで人は死にませんからね
それぐらいのことでバックすればいいんですね
ですから
分析してみなくてはならないんです
世の中のことは
我々はどんな仕事で完璧性を求めるべきですか
どんな世界でまあいいやと認めるべきですか
という　分析的に世の中を見る必要があるんですよ
見たところで
ここら辺は大目に見てもよろしいと
ここら辺は厳密に見なくては
厳密に見なくてはならないんだと
ここら辺は要注意だと
例えば高速バスやらね
交通ものね
使っている運転手さんたちとかは
ものすごい要注意して仕事をしなくちゃいけない
タクシー運転手さんであろうとも
かすかな事故も起こしてはならないんですよ
個人の自分の車だったら勝手にもういいんですけど
ぶつかったらインシュアランスで
お金もらっちゃいますからね
でも個人でも事故を起こしてはいけませんし
人に怪我させない場合は
どうってことないかもしれませんけど
でもタクシー運転手さんみたいなプロの場合は
わずかなかすり傷でも自分の車についちゃうと
ちょっと心配なんですよ
高速バスやらのバスを運転する人々やらね
そういう人々はたくさんの人の命を預かっているんだから
自分の仕事は完璧にしなくちゃいけない
でも少々失敗したとしても
それほど死にませんから
それは要注意するべき世界なんですね
医者の場合は要注意ではないんですよ
確実に完璧にやりなさいと
ということを言わなくてはいけないんですね
そういうふうなことで
世の中の人間の生き方っていうのは
無視したとしてもいいところもある
放っておいたとしてもいいところもある
やっぱり一言いって直したところもある
注意した方がいいところもある
ものすごく厳密に注意した方がいいところもある
完璧でなければならないところもある
そのリストを持って世の中生きていれば
それほど世の中に問題は起こらないと思いますね
そこで次のポイントなんですけど
我々はなぜ失敗するかっていうこと
そんなに頑張っているのに
そんなに真剣にやっているのに
なぜ仕事を失敗するんですかね
それも大事なポイントなんですよ
具体的な例で言えば
例えば試験には一生懸命真面目に勉強はしたんだけど
試験は失敗してしまったとかね
仕事の場合でも一生懸命やったんだけど
結局は失敗してしまったと
何なのかと
そんな一生懸命やっているのに
その場合もやっぱり少々分析して考えないと
いくつかの原因は考えられます
その中で一番大きな原因は
過剰自信なんですよ
自分がプロだと
もう分かったもんだと
慣れたもんだと
どうってことないんだと
任せておけと
という感じでいろんな仕事に手を出す
その過剰自信が危険の第1
あの原子放射能の事件が起きたのは
何のことなく過剰自信
いくつか原子炉で事故を起こしたでしょうに
すべて過剰自信
過剰自信で手を抜く
大丈夫だ
なんであんな過剰自信するんですかね
不完全であるということは忘れているんですよ
原子炉はもう完璧に作ったんだからと思っても
不完全であると
一つの原子炉で何か
ハードボード
なんとか水を使ってクーリングしますね
冷却 そこで冷却といってものすごい恐ろしく熱いんだけど
それはなんとかパイプで水を流れていますけど
そういうのはものすごい専門的なところで
厳密にレントゲンで見ながら作っているものなんですけど
それでもどこかでほんのちょっとの欠陥が
入ったりして
どうしても見つかりっこはないぐらいの
ほんのちょっとのとこなんですよ
でも　ものすごい熱い
すごい圧力で水が流れていると
どんどん金属疲労でそこら辺で割れ目が入っちゃったりする
だから　完璧だ
大丈夫だということは危険なんですよ
どれほど技術能力でそういうものを作っても
やっぱり何かあるかもしれませんという二重
三重　四重ぐらいの安全ということを
考えなくてはいけませんね
これで間違ったらこれで直るぞと
これで間違ったらこれで直るぞという
この過剰自信
一番問題なんですよ
運転する人で
私にとっては目を閉じてでも運転できるぞとか思ったら
すぐ死んじゃいますからね
運転手さんの中でも
私は自分の国でよく聞いたんだけど
免許なしに何人かに聞いたんだけども
何年も運転しているんですよ
だから車小さい時から
いじったりして
せいぜい車座れるぐらい背が高くなっちゃったら
あっちこっち運転してみたりする
どんどん自信がついちゃって
道路でも運転したりして
大体事故を起こさないと警察は
調べるということはしませんから
ただ道路で車行くたびに調べる必要ないでしょうし
全然警察に見つかったことも何もなくて
それで1年
2年経っちゃうと1年
2年も経ちますよ
無免許で運転したりして
やっぱり大人が心配していくらなんでももうあんたは
車を運転もできるんだから免許を取りなさいと言ったら
まあ行って免許を取る
もう何のことなく1回で免許証合格してもらっちゃう
ある人が言ったんですよ
免許を取って1週間経ったところで捕まったんだと
私は2年も運転していたのに
無免許で捕まったことはなかったんだと
だから免許取りたてで何か問題起こす
捕まっちゃったら
それも免許にもちょっと良くないでしょうに
どういうことかというと
免許を取れたんだ
あの紙1枚もらっちゃったんだから
もう過剰自信
もう怖いものはないんだと
だから　たとえ免許証をもらっても
車を運転するたびに要注意するということは
一生なんですよ
40年間車を運転したんだから
もう心配する必要ないんですかね
あるんですよ
それでも
ですから
人間にこの過剰自信というものがついちゃって
それは良くない
危険 お釈迦様その場合もこういう偈がありまして
自分が知ってるんだと思ったらアホになるんだと
自分がそれほどもう知ってるわけじゃないと思ったら
もう毎日毎日その人の智慧が増えていくんだと
という意味の言葉があるんですよ
直訳するとちょっと意味が変わりますけど
Yo bālo
maññati bālyaṃ
paṇḍito vāpi tena so
もし愚か者が自分が愚か者であることを知っているならば
それだけで彼がpaṇḍito賢者ですよと
ただそれだけのことで
私は愚か者だと認めてるんだったら
もうじりじりと賢者になるんだと
Bālo ca paṇḍitamānī
頭が悪いのに
愚か者であるのに
paṇḍitamānī
私はもう賢者だよと
物事を知っているんだと思ったら
sa ve bālo ti vuccati
その人はずっと愚か者だと
無知な人になるんだという言葉なんですね
だからそちらに言っているのは
この過剰自信ということなんですね
だから　そこそこは知ってるんだと
そこそこはできるんだということを
自分の頭の中で置いておくと
過剰自信がなくなっちゃう
毎日毎日頭が進んでいくんです
訓練の場合は
毎日毎日自分の腕が磨いていくんですよ
だから　よく世の中で見えるものが
技術は世界一だとか
何でも世界一論を持ってくるんですね
だから何でしょうかね
技術は世界一だと言ったら
もしかすると技術は世界一かもしれません
でもそれは技術は完璧だという意味じゃありませんよ
よく私の耳に入りますからね
やっぱりもう我々の技術はもう世界一だとかね
日本は神の国だと言ったような感じで
勝手に何言ったとしても私は気にしませんだけど
もう大したことはないんですけど
でもそこで危険なところがあるんですよ
論理性 世界の技術と比べてみたら
自分の技術は世界一かもしれません
それで別に悪いわけじゃないんですよ
だからと言って完璧ではありません
そこでちょっとしたミスを犯しちゃうんですよ
本当に確かにたくさん品物ありますよ
日本でしか作れないものっていうのは
技術的なもの
科学的なものもいっぱいありますよ
日本でしか作れない
他のとこで作るんだけど
どうもうまくいかないとかね
だからその点でやっぱり世界一だというのは
間違ってはないんです
でも人間はそれはそこまで間違ってないんだけど
世界一ということは完璧という意味ではないんだと
それでもどこかで　どうぞ足を伸ばしてください
足が痛い方々はどうぞ気楽に座ってください
世界一の技術であろうとも
いろいろ直さなくちゃいけないところ
さらに進歩させなくちゃいけないところ
いっぱいあるんだと
安全だと
完璧だと言ってほっとすることは
絶対できませんということは理解してもらわないと
だから　失敗を起こす原因の一番大きい原因はそれなんです
過剰自信
謙虚じゃないんですよ
頭が 知ってるんだと
たとえもう外科医の教授であろうとも
25歳からもう
50歳になるまでずっと手術してきたんだと思っても
プロ中のプロで
それでも一個一個の手術にすごい真剣でやってもらわないと
困るんですよ
日本にそういうケース一つ起きたでしょ
エイズの感染問題で
血液なんとか薬をね
加熱処理しないで使ってもいいんだと
あの方が決していい加減な教授ではなかったんですよ
大変な一流のものすごい素晴らしい教授でしたけど
逆にアホでしたから
正しい科学者であるならば
1万分の1でも問題が起こるんだったら
気をつけなくちゃいけないんですよ
加熱処理しなかった薬を入れただけで
病気でかかったことはないんだと思っても
1人でもなったならば危険なんですよ
なぜかというと
その患者にその薬になってたらどうするんですかね
それでたくさんの人を大変不幸なことに
してしまっちゃったんです
その時も
その人がデータを持っていたんですよ
研究データ
持っていたんだけど
どこかで過剰自信で
この割合で計算してね
いくつかのケースが出ていたんだけど
みんななったわけじゃないんだと
そんないい加減さで人が死んじゃいますからね
だからプロ中のプロになってくると
なんかすごく高慢になってしまって
過剰自信になるんですよ
そこはどんなプロでもすごく気をつけなくちゃ
いけないことなんですよ
なぜかというと
プロ中のプロになると
自分には目上の人がなくなっちゃうんですよ
みんな弟子たちだから
生徒たちだから
それでもみんな先生どうですか？
この場合はどうですか
この場合はどうですか？
ってみんな自分から聞くんだから
自分の言ったことは神の言葉のように
生徒たちが聞いているんだから
そうするとついついなってしまっちゃう
ですから
たとえある分野で世界一のプロになっても
世界一プロっていうのは
その人の上
誰もいないということなんですよ
そこで　その人にとってはみんな小さく見えるんです
他に小さく見えるんだからといって
自分が完璧というわけじゃないんですね
それでも本当に自分の心の謙虚ということは
守ってもらわないと失敗は起こるんですよ
そうでないと失敗は起こりません
プロの世界では
ですから
一番大事な問題というのは過剰自信であること
それもプロにもよく起こる現象で
プロでない人にもたまたま起きたりして
そこで失敗する
で　自信ついちゃったらね
過剰自信ついちゃったらね
気をつけた方がいい
ほとんどの場合は失敗する
試験の場合でも
ああ　これは私にできるぞと思ったら失敗する
だからこの過剰自信を置いておく
少々やばいと思った方がいいんですよ
ちゃんとチャレンジしないと
ちゃんとチャレンジしないといけないんだと
全身でもうアプローチしないと
うまくいかないということを理解してほしいんですね
次に失敗する原因というのはそれほど
大したことではないんだけど
わかりやすいことで
あまり気が入らない
中途半端でね
嫌で嫌でやると
やってあげますとかね
やっぱりやらなくちゃいけないんだとかね
そういう
あんまりこの真剣さがなくなっちゃうと失敗しちゃう
時々　人っていうのは仕事を軽く見るという
性格があるんですよ
それぐらいのことかと
それは大体単純な仕事でよく出てくることなんですよ
例えばずっと
20年間も主婦をなさった方がいるとする
だから20年間も料理なんか作ってきたんだから
もう慣れたもんですよ
そうすると
軽く見ちゃう
もう料理のプロだから
事故起きたりします
天ぷら油に火がついたりとかね
起きたりします
時々何回も家が火事になったりとかね
あったでしょ
ああいうのは
毎日やっていたことだから
20年間もやってきたんだからね
事故を起こしたことないんですよ
そうすると
軽いと思っちゃうんですね
その軽いと思うところが危険なんですよ
たとえ炊飯器でご飯を炊く時でも
毎日炊いてもちゃんと水の量は
チェックした方がいいんです
何十年経っても
何十年間もご飯炊いても
毎回毎回水の量をチェックした方がいいんです
そうでないとどこかでちょっと失敗する可能性ありますね
だから
それほど難しい仕事ではありません
というふうな気持ちもよくないんですよ
私が言いたいのは
たとえこれは拭いてくださいと雑巾で言ったら
そんなこと簡単だ
なんでつまらないことを頼むんですかと
という気持ちでやっちゃうとうまくできないんですよ
その　ただ雑巾をかける仕事であろうとも
真剣でそれなりに
それは大体日本の禅宗ではそういう話はよくありますよ
仕事はどんな単純な仕事でも
これはもう単純じゃないんだ
そういう言葉ではないんだけど
こちらプロの方々がいますけど
なんて言いますか
つまらない仕事とすごい面白い仕事
そんなことはありはしないんだと
たとえ掃除にしても
ほうきをかけることにしても
はたきでほこりをたたくことにしても
一つ一つ大事な仕事なんですよ
その仕事にはやり方があるんですよ
目的があるんですよ
そこで 100点満点でやらなくちゃいけないんです
だから　それも人間に必要なこと
ついつい掃除機かけると
なんとかさっさとかけて回ったりする
仕事を軽く見るということはよくないんですね
何一つも軽く見てはいけません
トイレに行くことにしても
軽く見るんだから
トイレに行って帰ると電気がついたまんまでしょうに
家を出るたびにもう慣れたもんだと思ってはいけません
ちゃんと電気消したか
ガス消したか
鍵をかけたかとかね
それ中途半端なとこ私もありますけど
今はいつでも鍵を忘れることはないはめになってますけどね
前は大体別にということにもあったんですけどね
ですから
そういういい加減なところはどんな人間にもありますよ
私にも言えないぐらいいっぱいありますけど
いい加減なところは
でもやっぱり一つ一つ仕事を軽く見ないで
真剣にやるということは大変大事なんですね
それ軽く見て私も結構損したことはありますよ
軽く　ああ
こんな軽い軽いと思ったところで失敗しまして
その失敗を直すためにお金まで結構かかったりとかね
悔しいんですよ
なんでこれとこれ調べなかったんですかと
知ってるつもりでやったんだからとかね
自分のことを悔しがったりするんだけど
やっぱり単純な仕事であろうが
雑巾かけることであろうが
ホコリをはたきでたたくことであろうが
単純だと思ったら何か問題が起こるんです
ですから
過剰自信は良くないことと
どんなことでも仕事でも軽く見ないことと
軽く見ないことですごくいいポイントもありますよ
つまらないと
そんな単純だと
なんで私がこれまでこれもやらなくちゃあかんかと
そんな気持ちで仕事をすると
まず仕事は中途半端で失敗だらけでもあるし
やった人も気持ちが悪いんですよ
例えば　ある人にあなた
トイレの掃除をお願いしますと言ったら
なんで私はトイレ掃除に任されるんですか？
とかね と思っちゃうと
そのトイレ掃除もろくにやれませんし
本人はやったんだけど
すごい気持ちが悪い
そういうことはもう不幸なんですね
だから道路であんたビラを
配ってくださいと頼まれたら
それは大事な仕事として
すごい気持ちよくやればいいんです
例えば　どこかの店にバイトに行ったところで
レジは任せてくれない
その代わりに床の掃除しなさいと言ったら
その道具を持って一生懸命
気持ちよくそれをやればいいんですよ
そうするとぴったしきれいになりました
という気持ちもあるし
仕事を頼んだ人にとっても
よく真面目にやってくれるんだと
という気持ちも出てきて
明るく終わっちゃうんですよ
ですから
仕事にはもう上と下はないことね
それは日本では常識ですけどね
常識は常識ですけど
やっぱりやるときはそうじゃないんですね
どうも課長にならなきゃ気が済まない人もいるんだからね
部長にならなきゃ気が済まない
課長にならなきゃ気が済まない
総理大臣にならなくちゃ
気が済まないという人がいるんだから
なったところで失敗だらけなんでしょうに
だから総理大臣にならなくてもいいんですよ
課長　部長にならなくてもいいんですよ
自分に任された仕事はきれいに
真剣にやればいいんですね
2番目の原因はそれなんですね
仕事は面白くないとかね
私にはすごいたくさんのことができるのに
なんでそんなことを頼むんですかという
軽く見ることと過剰自信と
できるんだという過剰自信と
なんでそんなつまらないことを頼むんですかという
それも高慢なんですけど
間でいくつかの原因がありますけど
大体集中しないでね
ながら族でテレビを見ながら天ぷらを揚げるとかね
そういう場合もいろいろトラブル起きたりする
それから言われるんだから
母親に言われるんだから
勉強すると勉強はうまくいかないんですね
命令されたんだからやると
うまくいかない
そういういくつかの原因がありますね
失敗する原因は
休憩何時ですか？
一応前回でこのなぜ失敗するかという原因
本当は2つしか言ってないんだけども
間でもいろいろたくさんありますけど
それは全部言う必要はないと思います
大体は中途半端で
何か他のことを何かやりながら
あるいはあまり興味がなくて
あるいは言われるんだからとか
そういう気持ちでいろんなことをやると
ほとんどの場合は失敗する
そこら辺はたくさんありますけど
あまりご自分でもお分かりになるだろうと思います
次に休憩なぜ取るかというと
2番目になってくると結構きつくなる
完璧主義って一体何なのかと
ということなんです
完璧であることを
あるいは完璧になりたいという気持ち自体が
お釈迦様から言えば邪見なんですよ
正しい考え方じゃないんです
正見ではありません
それにチャレンジすると
その人々は邪見に基づいてチャレンジするんだから
決して幸福になるわけじゃありませんと
この邪見という言葉
micchā　diṭṭhi
間違っている考え方っていうのは
仏教ではまあそれは大変な厳しいこととして
言ってるんですよ
お釈迦様も人を脅したりとかね
そういうことはあまりしませんけど
人の失敗なんかはそれほど気にしなかったし
人が罪を犯しても
あんまりそんなに真剣に気にする
ということはないんですよ
でも　何も罪を犯さなくても
考え方がおかしいんだったら
すごく重罪を犯したような人の感じで
しゃべったりするんですね
それで罪もいろいろリストがあるんだけど
軽い罪から重い罪まで一番重い罪になっているのは
邪見なんですよ
それも一般的には世の中で認めないかもしれません
仏教では人殺しよりも邪見が重い罪なんですよ
本当にそんなそうですか？
と思うかもしれません
でもそうなんです
どういうことかというと
人間が自分の考え方によって生き方を構成するんですよ
調整するんですよ
我々はどんな生き方をしているんですか？
どんな行動をしているんですかと
すべて本人が心で決まっている
自分なりの自分だけのポリシーに基づいているんですよ
それは自分自身の哲学なんですよ
どんな人間も
私の哲学というものは持っているんですよ
子供は子供の哲学を持っていて
母親は母親の哲学を持っているんです
それで母親の言う通りにやるわけじゃないんですよ
先生の言う通りにやるわけじゃないんですよ
みんな自分が持っている哲学に基づいて
これ哲学と言うんでしょうか
わかりませんだけど
まあポリシーですけどね
自分が自分の心で
決めているポリシーによって生活しているんですよ
たとえ私がこんなことを喋ったとしても
みんな同じくならないんでしょうに
決して変わらない人もいるんだけど
なかなか同じくはならないんですよ
それはなぜかというと
私の話は
ご自分の哲学という自分の人生論
人生観という器に入れて使っているんだから
そういうことで
個人差っていうのは出てくる
平等になるということはないんです
みんな同じくなるということ
そういうことだから
個人が持っている哲学
ポリシー
理論　ものの見方っていうのは大変大事なことなんです
そこはすべての決まり手なんですよ
すべてのものの
そういうことだから
人が人を殺したかないかということよりも
大事なのは
その人が持っている自分なりの理念なんですよ
そこは間違っているとどうなるんでしょうかね
どうしようもないんですよ
例えば　人がたまたま腹が立って人を殺したりする
それでも自分の理念というのは
自分が立派な人間では生活したいんだという理念だったら
その人を直せるんですよ
本当は立派な人間で生きていきたいんだと
たまたまいろいろ事件も条件があって
人を殺してしまったということだから
その人には立ち直ることは何のことなくできる
もし自分の理念が間違っているんだったら
どうにもならないんですよ
ですから
罪の中で一番重い罪が何なのかと
仏教から聞くと理念なんです
個人が持っている理念
個人の哲学
個人が持っているポリシー
そこは邪見になってほしくないんですよ
完璧にはならないんだからね
それは完璧にはならないんだけど
邪見にしては欲しくないんですね
だからこの完璧主義っていうのは邪見ですということは
どういうことかとこれから説明します
お釈迦様がすべてのものは無常であると
すべて変化するんだと
それから無常と同時にdukkhaという言葉を教えたんですね
dukkhaの意味は
感覚的には苦しいという意味なんですけど
哲学的には無常であることと
不完全であることなんですよ
すべてのものは
心と物事
一切のものが不完全なんです
どう見ても見えるものはすべて不完全でしょうに
不完全だから物事変化するんですよ
だから花が咲いたら
大体この花は完全だよと思っても
花にとっては満開になった
花にとっては自分が完璧な状態に
なったわけじゃないんですよ
あれは他の状態のための準備段階だけなんですよ
ですから
花が次の状態になるんですよ
その状態になっても
それは完全な状態ではありません
その状態が次の段階に状態に
変えなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから止まることは物事にないんです
完全になったらそれで終わりなんです
それ以上成長する必要はなくなっちゃうんですね
だから種は不完全だから
種は芽が出るためのものだからね
だから芽が出る
それは不完全だからちょっと伸びちゃう
それが不完全だから葉っぱが出てくるとか
その状態は不完全だからどんどん変わっていく
だから一つの状態でも完全ではありません
完全だったらそこでピタッと止まるはずなんです
ですから
不完全イコール無常なんです
完璧という概念が完璧になりたい
完璧主義の私は完璧やとか思う人々が
無常に逆らって無常でありませんと
という科学的な真理に逆らって
逆さまのことを考えているんですよ
だから邪見なんです
その邪見に戻して生活すると
もう出てくるのは必ずしもトラブル
苦しみ　悩み
問題なんです
ですから
完全主義というのはもう正真正銘の邪見なんです
完璧主義というのは
ありえないんです
それはもう面白くないと言ってもしょうがないんですよ
あなたは何言ったって私は完全だと
思ってもしょうがないことなんですね
だから邪見的に人の機嫌を取ってしゃべる場合は
何でもしゃべれますよ
あなた方は神の子供ですよとかね
何でもかっこいい言葉を言えるんですけど
そういうふうに言う人々もいますね
人間は神様が作ったんだから
神の子供ですよと
みんな気持ちいいんですよ
神の子で気持ちいいんだけど
だらしないのはそのままでしょうに
そんなこと言ってくれたとしても
どこで我々の生き方に役に立つんですかね
だから美しい言葉かもしれませんよ
人々のことをすごく褒めて
言ってくれる言葉なんですけど
絶対たる神様の直々の言葉だと
素晴らしい言葉ですけど
役には立ちません
ちょっとイメージしてみてください
私は神様の息子ですよと
娘ですよと
それでどうなりますかね
それで危険を起こす可能性はいくらでもありますけど
うまくいく可能性はないんですよ
だから私はより良い人間にならなくちゃいけない
という論理になりません
だから父親は神様だからね
何が失敗したとしてもね
全部向こうはなんとかしてくれるんだということで
緊張さがなくなっちゃうんですよ
生きることの緊張さというんですかね
緊張というものはなくなっちゃうんですよ
ですから
注意深く生きていなくちゃいけないということが
消えちゃうんです
同じく仏教の世界でみんな仏様の息子だよと
言ったとしても同じことなんですよ
みんな本来悟ってるんだとか何とか言ったとしてもね
本覚だと言ったとしても役に立ちません
でも言葉自体は大変
人間のことをすごく尊く考えて言ったことかもしれません
もしかすると
そんなことを最初に言った人々が
自分が世の中を見るとどんな目で見ているんですかと
他人を見ると自分のアプローチだよと言った方が
ものすごいかっこいいのに
だからブッダの教えでもいいし
誰の教えでもいいんだけど
こういう仏教を信じている人々が
他人様を見る時はみんな仏様だとという気持ちで
見た方がいいんじゃないか
そういうふうに見たら
自分の生き方が必ず謙虚的になって
すごく気をつけて生きることになります
そこで言葉が間違っちゃうんですね
間違って本来悟っているんだよと言って開き直る
開き直って修行をやめる
努力することをやめちゃう
それから失敗する
堕落するということにはなりますね
ですから
お釈迦様の教えになってくると
あんまり大胆なことを人間は褒めてないし
まあ不完全だと
お釈迦様はよく使っている言葉って
愚か者という言葉だからね
神の子という言葉使ってないんです
私の子という言葉は全然使いません
愚か者という言葉を使っているんです
パーリ語だったらbālaという言葉
その点でも仏教の教えの態度っていうのは
ちょっときついと言えばきついんですけどね
だから
先生が生徒たちを叱るような感じなんですね
でも甘い
もう何でもいいやで無視する先生よりは
ちょっとまあ
何て言いますか
スズメバチみたいに
ちょっと間違ったら刺すというぐらいの先生だったら
やっぱりもう無邪気な生徒たちがね
しっかりするんでしょうし
そういうことだから
すべてのものは不完全である
だから変化していく
その中に完全性っていうのは認めることはできません
ありえない
それなのに
人間の心の中で完全主義という気持ちが
みんなの心の中には入り込んでいる
それは邪見であると
それは見方が狭いんだからなるんですよ
次のポイントなんですけど
なんで心の中にそういう問題が起こるかと
こういう例で考えましょう
あるお母さんに生まれた子が障害があるとする
そのお母さんが世の中の他の子供を見たことがないならば
子供は見たことがない
見たのは唯一の自分の子供だけ
障害があってもわかりますかね
自分の子供には生まれつき何か欠点があるんだと
わかりますかね
それでなぜ自分の子供が何か欠点を持って
生まれたんだとわかるかというと
他の人の子供と比べるからでしょ
自分の子供の成績が悪いんだとどうやってわかるんですかね
何かと比べるからわかるんであって
そうでなきゃ問題がないんですよ
自分の家に咲いた花が
それはそれできれいなんですけど
きれいな花だなと思って
隣の家の庭の花も見ると
見ちゃうとそちらの方がもっと綺麗で
もっと立派という風に見えちゃうと
自分のものは小さく見えちゃうんですね
そういうこと
あるいは自分の庭の花を見たら
花も咲いていることで
どうったことないやと思っている人がいるとします
これ反対側
そう思っていたところで
そっちへ散歩すると
人の庭も見る
そちらも花が咲いてるんだけど
それほど庭も大きくはないし
花の手入れしてないし
肥料もあげてないし
水もかけてないし
だから花も小さくて変化して
あまりかっこよくない
それで　あっ
私の庭の花は一番だと
という気持ちになるんですよ
それでかっこつけちゃうんです
この住宅街で
私の庭の花は一番綺麗だと
高慢になる
最初はそうではなかったんですよ
花も咲いて当たり前だと
ちゃんと面倒見たんだからと
今の時期になると花が咲くのも当たり前で
っていうぐらいで落ち着いていたのに
隣と比べたところで余計なことになる
例えば逆に
自分の子供は小さい時からいつでも点数は
100点満点取ってくるんですね
毎日のことだから別にどうったことはない
それでも子供叱ったりとかいろいろしたり
もういい加減せんかとか何とか言ったりはする
それでいろいろ他のお母さんたちと
付き合うことになったりして
他の人々の情報やらいろいろ調べたところで
みんなもう
100点取った人は一人もいないと
自分の子供だけだとわかったところから大変なんですね
うちの子はまあこういう子やと
それでまた自慢したり
高慢になったりする
だからそれはどこから出てくる問題ですか
完全の問題は比べるから出てくる問題なんですよ
比較する
この比較することは仏教での用語でmānaと言うんですね
あるいは日本語で慢
高慢という言葉で使っている慢なんですね
比べてみると
自分と他人を
自分と他人を比べてみれば
いくらでも悲観的になるとこはいくらでもありますよ
悔しくなることはいくらでもありますよ
ですから
この比較することはすごい煩悩なんですよ
比較することは不可能なんです
この花と他の花っていうのはどうやって比較するんですかね
木が違うんだから枝も違いますから
当たる光も違いますから
失礼なんですよ
お姉ちゃんと弟を比べると
これ失礼なんですよ
自分の子供同士でも比べないでしょうに
一人が年上で一人が年下だから
だからとんでもないことをやっているんですよ
我々は みんなすごい苦労するでしょ
痩せるために比べては痩せたくなる
どんどん針のように痩せても気がつかないかもしれませんよ
どんどん人間痩せてしまっちゃって
竹ぐらいに痩せちゃったところで
それでも他のものに比べて
もっと痩せたいと思うかもしれません
それぐらい行き過ぎに
まだなってないんだけど
もう行き過ぎになるってことはありますよ
ブランド思考やらね
アクセサリーの思考やらおしゃれの思考やらね
全部比べる世界でしょ
行って行ってどこまで行くかと
行って苦しみばっかり作っちゃうんですよ
比べるんだから
この限定品という思考まで出ているんですよ
くだらんカバンですけど
これは限定品で
1万個しか作ってないんだと
それで番号もちゃんと付いているんだと
いくらでもお金払って買う
何のためでしょうかとかね
ただ心の変な病気でしょうに
だから比べるということは一番大きな問題で
比べることは煩悩であって
愚か者しか物事を比べないんですよ
これ科学的じゃないんです
比べるということ
だから一つ一つのものが別なものなんですよ
たとえ似ていても
例えば私が写真撮って
写真 ３枚
コピー 3枚もらったとする
同じものですかね
3枚も別々なものなんです
比べることはできないんです
別な紙でしょうし
別な薬品でしょうし
ですから
普通の世間で我々はいろんなものに尺度を持ってね
比べたり測ったりいろいろしますけど
それは人生にはダメなんです
1日中何グラムぐらいお塩を使いますかと
何グラムぐらい砂糖使いますかとかね
それは測ってもいいんだけど
人生においては比べることは無知な行為なんです
知恵の行動じゃないんですね
だからできれば頭から物事を比べることを捨ててしまえば
もう比較する相手がないんだから
もう完成
完璧か不完全か
そんなことを気にしなくなっちゃうんです
そのものがそのもので放っておくんですよ
上の子がすごい体力があって
体がすごいでっかいと
下の子はいつでもやせっぽちで弱いんだと
放っておけばいいんですよ
そんなことは
筋肉がつかない
あまり食べない
下の子もそのままでいいし
その子はすごい筋肉ついてる
もう体ができている子供と同じくやろうとしちゃうと
みんなに不幸
やられる側にも
やる側にも
だから何一つも比べることは不可能であって
比べたがる気持ちが煩悩であると
自分の心が汚れているんだからそうなっているんだ
ということをもし理解できれば
完璧主義というのはもう飛んじゃいますよ
だから比較すること
比べることをしなくなったならば
消える現象だから
それは独立して世の中にあることじゃないんですよ
完璧主義っていうことは
ただそれだけのことはすごい簡単単純なことなんです
まだ逆な見方もありますよ
まだ逆な見方あります
全部完全ではないかと
例えば花が咲いた
でも花びらが
一つ二つ伸びてないんだと
小さいんだと
花の種類によってもありますが
例えばバラの花にしても
あるところで花びらが短かったら
あまりいい花じゃないんですよ
形として丸く見えないんですね
あ　この花が不完全だと言えるのは
他のバラの花と比べる時ですよ
ちゃんと花びらが同じ大きさで伸びてるんだったら
これは完璧な花で
この花が完璧じゃないんだと
見ちゃう
比べると逆な見方で見れば
そのこの花がそれしかできないんですよ
その花が
花びらが短い花が
それは自分にできる精いっぱいのことをしているんですよ
わざと短くしたわけじゃないんです
種 2つ植えたところで
1本はすごく太って芽が出てきて
1本はすごく細くてと
それはその
2つの種が自分にできる能力をいっぱい発揮しているんですよ
何も欠けてるわけじゃないんです
完璧なんです
生まれてきた子供の目が見えないとしても
それは不完全な状態じゃないんですよ
それはその
DNA が組み立てたところで
一番
百点満点で出した結果ですよ
それ以上出せません
それで完全ですよ
例えば 1500
CC の軽自動車を運転して
その車はせいぜい
65 キロしかスピードを出せないと言っても
その車が自分の能力をフルに使っているんですよ
何か欠けてるわけじゃないんです
それはなんで3500
リッターの車に比べるんですかね
その比べ方は間違ってるんですよ 3500
リッターの車がスピードは
100 以上出すっていうのはそちらの能力なんですよ
ですから
世の中はこのままでいいんですよ
見方によります
比べるか比べないかと
だから比べないで見ると
それはそれでいいんですよ
英語上手な日本の方がいるとする
いくら勉強したとしても
なかなか心に留まらない
日本のもう一人の人もいる
いいじゃない
放っておけば
その人の能力はそれぐらいだから
だからもう今も電気
4つぐらいついてますけど
これは太陽の光のように何千万ワットぐらいの
エネルギーを出してほしいと思ったら
それとんでもない話でしょ
これは日本武道館の明かりと比べる必要はありますかね
日本武道館だったらもっと明るいでしょうとかね
だからそこはものすごい非科学的なんですよ
どんなものも完全ですよ
見方を変えてみれば
例えばこの台はちょっと傾いているとする
そこで私はビー玉一つ落としちゃったら
ビー玉が転がっていくでしょ
転がってて
どこかで止まるんですよ
だからそこでいいということなんです
だから物事は因果法則によって生まれるんだという
お釈迦様の話がありますね
それも仏説ですけど
因果法則から考えちゃうと
原因条件そろったら結果が出る
そちらには完全だ
不完全だということはあり得ない話なんです
私は両手叩いたら音が出るでしょうに
それは音は不完全だと言えますかね
両手はどのように叩いたかと
叩いたかと
手のどこら辺
どこら辺に触れたかと
空気の温度はどれぐらいですかと
部屋の何とか条件はどれぐらいですかとか
それによって音の響きやら強さやら決まってるんですよ
それ以上もそれ以下も出せません
こうやって音をするでしょうに
それは完全な音で
こうやってしたらそれは完全な音なんです
前の音と次の音を比べちゃうと変なんですけど
だから　ある子供はものすごくヒステリーになって
キャーキャーキャーと泣いていると
それは変な子供ではなくて
その子供が置かれている条件によって
そういう結果しか出せないだけなんですよ
笑えないんです
その時は
そういう条件に置かれているんだから
この子はいつまでも泣いて
なんで他の子供と同じく笑ってくれないかと言ったとしても
それはこちらの考え方が間違っているんであって
比べているんだから
それはそれで完全なんです
完全というのは
ですから
まあ完全主義と言うならば
言いたければ別に言ったとしてもいいんですよ
でも知識に知恵に基づいて言いたいんです
言ってほしいんです
文句言ってはいけません
完全だと思うならば
すべてことごとく完全なんです
なんで文句を言うんですかと
不完全だと言いたければ
すべてことごとく不完全なんです
文句言う必要ないんです
だから犬を見ても
同じ種類の犬にしても
毛の長さはそれぞれまちまちでしょうに
その体では作られるぐらいのギリギリの
ところまで毛を伸びていますよ
色も同じことでしょうに
それぞれの体で出せるぐらいの色を出しているんです
なんで白い犬が黒い犬になってほしいと思いますかね
なんで毛が短い犬が毛が伸びてほしいと思いますかね
そこは人間の比べる世界だから出てくることなんです
比べる世界はまた高慢であって
慢であって無知だから出てくるんですね
そういうことだから
完全主義も不完全主義もね
どうして当てにならない
人間のうわごとにしか何もないんじゃないかなと思いますけどね
ですから
そういうことだから
花は力いっぱい咲いてますよ
たとえ花びらが2つ3つ欠けていても
その花自体が力いっぱい
100パーセントで頑張っているんです
それはもう花だからそうなんですよ
石一つ投げちゃったら
その石が転がって転がって
自分が安定できるところで止まるんです
自然の世界では
人間にも同じことを考えてみれば
人間が自分の意思で努力するところが
自分の100パーセントを出しちゃえばいいんです
自分の努力で
それが比べる必要ないんです
比べると不完全になるんであって
比べないと不完全でも何でもなく
これは自分の百パーセントの力の結果ですよと
それで腹が立ったり困ったりする必要なくなっちゃうんです
だから　完璧主義の場合は
人間に対して喋る場合は
人間が自分で考えて行動しているんですよ
その時は中途半端で手抜きで
ながら族で
何かやりながらやったりとか
そういうことではなくて
集中して
それには自分の100パーセント出す能力
そうすると100パーセントの結果が出る
その結果は他の人のものと比べる必要はないんです
幼稚園の子供が描く文章であろうが絵であろうが
すごい綺麗でしょ？
かっこいいんです
大人になってくるとどうってことはないんです
なぜかというと
子供なんか字一つ書いても
鉛筆はギューッと握って
力いっぱい出して書いてるんですよ
紙も一部折れたりする場合もありますけど
なんとかすごく可愛いんですよ
あれで力いっぱいでやっているんだから
やっと自分の名前書いただけかもしれませんよ
でも　ちっちゃな子供は自分で鉛筆をにぎって名前書いたら
あれはすっごいいい作品なんですよ
子供の心も見えるし
年もわかるし
可愛いということも感じてくるし
それは書道のプロの文字となんで比べるんですかね
それ大人になってくると
我々はよく失敗するんですね
人と比べて
人と比べているだけで
自分の力いっぱいというものは出さなくなっちゃうんですね
だから力いっぱい出せないのは間違いなんですよ
力いっぱい出すと
それはそれでもう完璧です
他のことはありえないんです
大体はこの完璧主義っていうのは
それほど難しいテーマではありません
難しく喋るならば
いくらでも喋れますけど
それは因果法則ということも考えなくちゃいけないし
因縁の法則で物事は条件によって生まれてくるんだということに
だから条件によって生まれてくるんだから
その結果しか出せません
因果法則だから
マッチをね
ボックスの薬ついているところに
適当な力で刺したら火が出る
それはダイナマイトにはなりません
爆発はしません
マッチは自分に持っている力いっぱい出す
そこは完全か不完全かということになり立たないんですよ
もしマッチ棒についている薬の中に
いろいろ不純物なんか入っていたならば
火がなんか変な形で出る
それでそのマッチがダメということじゃなくて
比べるダメなんですけど
そのマッチも自分に持っていたエネルギーは
力いっぱい出してるんですよ
そこでもう
1本のマッチをつけてもつけても火がつかなかったと
それはそのマッチが持っていた力なんです
薬は落ちちゃったんだけど
湿気が入ってしまっちゃって
火がつかなかったら
それはそちらの力いっぱいなんです
だから 1500CC
の車と 300CC
の車は比較しません
頭のいい人だったら
そういうことで
この因果法則っていうものは世の中であって
それによっていろんなことは出てくる
だから人間には意志という自分の気持ちで考える
ということがあるんだから
いろんな余計なことを考えたり
高慢をしたり
ストレス溜まったりとかね
そういうことをしないで
気持ちよく
明るく　毎日の仕事に
たとえつまらない仕事とか偉い仕事とか
そんな区別もなし
1秒
1秒何かやらなくちゃいけないんだから
その1秒1秒やることに専心的に力を絞ってやればいいんです
だとすごい人生は気楽になるし
明るくもなるし
問題は解決する
このテーマができちゃったのは
やっぱり人が自分のことを棚に上げて
いつでも他人から完璧性を求めるという
とんでもない
犯罪者だから
それは犯罪なんですよ
だから犯罪を起こしている人々の理屈を考えてみてください
同じ理屈なんですよ
自分にとって親切にしなかった
学校でちょっといじめられたんだ
それで閉じこもってしまって
誰か殺さなくちゃあかんと
よくそういう理屈で考えるんだから
いじめられる原因
自分にあったかないかと
それはどうでもいいんです
自分のことは
いじめに対して自分の対応が間違ったことは
それはどうでもいいんです
いじめにあったら
それを乗り越えればいいでしょうに
自分の問題だから
それなりの何とかできるでしょうに
先生に言うなり
警察に言うなり
親に言うなり
誰も聞かなかったら
もう紙でも書いていっぱい
私は何々さんで学校でいじめているんですけど
学校中そこらへんに書いて配ってしまえば
それで問題解決しますよ
簡単ですよ
いっぱいコピー用紙持ってきて
コピーして
1,000万脅してもらったと
1,000万かかりませんでしょうに
5,000円ぐらいあればあれぐらいのことできるでしょうに
じゃあできればこれからもやってみろと
だから頭ちょっと使えば
それなりになんとかね
先生も聞いてくれない
親も聞いてくれないと
警察に言っても馬鹿にされるんだと
だったらそれまで書いて
それも書いて
あっちこっち
そうやっても何か方法はあるんですよ
だからそこで子供の対応が
自分の対応が間違ったことも気にしないで
やっぱりそいつらを殺さなくちゃいけないんだと
社会全体的に間違っていると思ったりして
犯罪を起こしたりするでしょうに
それも結局
完璧主義者の問題なんですよ
だから　他人にいちいちいろいろ文句を言ったり
ケチをつけたり
もういろんなことをしたりする世界
いろいろ事件を起こしている子供たちの
心理と全く同じなんですね
思考パターンが
だから私はもう何も遠慮しないで
完璧主義の思考っていうのは犯罪だと
自分のことを気にしないで
他人から完璧性を認めるということは
単なる単純犯罪ですよと
そこで自分のところでもとにかく完璧にやりたい
完璧にやりたいというのは
それは無知
完璧っていうのは成り立たないんだと
自分が自分の力いっぱい出せばそれで十分だと
結果比較したらどうでも比較した時点で間違ってるんだから
だから完璧主義のいい面は
私が言いたいのは無知
愚かさ　完璧主義の悪い面について私は言いたいのは
それは犯罪という答えなんです
皆様も配って読み上げた
最初に読み上げた文章の中に
これを 2つに分けています
完璧主義はいい面で見れば
こういうこういうことで
几帳面で
こういうことでは悪い面で見ればこういうことだなと
2つ分けているんですよ
いい面について私は完璧主義者に言いたいのは
アホ ただの無知
悪い面について言いたいのは
あんたは犯罪者ですと
だから無知も良くないし
犯罪者も良くないんだから
完璧主義っていうのは成り立たないもので
捨てちゃえばいいんです
どんどん全てのものはね
無常であるということに気づいてくると
すごく心が落ち着いてくる
ということで
一応話は大体そこら辺ぐらいでは終了したいんだけど
もうちょっと余談なんですけど
完璧主義について考えたら
私は思い浮かんだ一つの例があったんですよ
あまり私は勉強していないんですけど
西洋でクリスチャンサイエンスというふうな
言葉ができちゃったんですね
キリスト教文化の中からできた考え方であって
ある宗教がね
既成的なキリスト教ではなくてね
いろいろカルト宗教団たくさん出ていますからね
キリスト教からは
神は完全であると決める
完全たる神様が不完全な世界は創造するはずがない
そこで神様が作ったこの世界は完全であると
故に　この世の中にあるものは全部
どんな不幸でも
どんな不公平なことでも
どうやって正当化するかと
それに頑張っちゃうんです
やり過ぎになっちゃって
もし人が病気になったら薬をあげる必要がない
それは神を侮辱することですと
そんな薬
点滴　と言うんですか？
それ それから
あれ　輸血
輸血する必要はありませんと
完璧に作っているんだから
お祈りさえすればいいと
というところまで持っていく
だからこの完璧主義っていうのはろくな結果に
ならないということだけ言いたいんですよ
あの人々は自分のカルト宗教はサイエンスと
名付けているんだけど
サイエンスでも何でもないんですよ
まあ理屈だけですよ
なぜかというと
神は完全でなければ
いい加減な不完全なものだったら創造はできないだろうと
できないですね
だろうではなくて
だから創造したものも完全ですと
故に　この世の中でみんないちいち言ってる
病気やらいろんなことはあるはずがないと
よく論理的に出来た結論ですね
だからあんなもう屁理屈もいいところで
そこでそんなにあまり扱ってはぐらいの例ではないんだけど
神は完璧ですとどうやって言えるんですかね
見たことも聞いたことも会ったこともないのに
どこかの人が言った話でしょうに
どこかの本に書いていることだけでしょうに
それに乗せられちゃって
みんなに迷惑をかけて
結構人死んじゃったんですよ
そういうカルトのおかげで
逆に仏教から見ると
世の中は不完全で不公平で
納得いかない
何を見ても
だからみんな頑張らなくちゃいけないんですよ
やっと生きてるだけなんですよ
それはそうじゃないと人が好き勝手に言いたくても
事実は事実なんです
生まれた赤ちゃんがそのまま放っておいちゃうと死んじゃうんです
たとえ完璧な神に作られたと思ったとしても
じゃあ放っておかないで
ただおっぱいだけあげるということにしましょう
あげて　なんとかご飯を食べられるところに
なっちゃったら放っておく
それでうまくいきますかね
何から何までも教えてあげなくちゃいけない
本人もすごく苦労して頑張らなくちゃいけない
人間っていうのは放っておいちゃうと言葉も喋れないでしょ
手も足も使えないんですよ
猿とチンパンジーと何の変わりもないんです
本当は我々は放っておけばチンパンジーになるはずでしたけどね
すごい苦労して頑張ってるんだから
こういう風な文化的な世界を作ってるんですよ
だから努力しなきゃ
頑張らなかったら何にも得られない世界
何の幸福も得られない世界
それはお釈迦様の見方
何にしてもすごい
努力しないと
平和でいるために
ものすごく努力しないと平和にならないんですよ
逆に戦争するためにも同じことなんですよ
怠けちゃったらダメです
死ぬだけで終わっちゃうんです
平和にしても
みんな活発的に行動しないと
人類が仲良くするようにと
いろんな意見
合わないところは全部まとめて頑張らないと平和にはならない
すごく努力しないと経済成長にはならない
そういうことだから
お釈迦様は人間の努力ということ
精進ということ
それは大変な大事な宝物として見ているんです
善として見ているんです
もし宗教の誰でも
この人間の精進
努力を否定しちゃうと
お釈迦様はその宗教には真っ向から反対する
それだけはよしてくれと
どんなくだらんことを言ってもいいんだけど
精進努力をやめることだけは教えないでくださいと
お釈迦様は心配で心配で
ただすべて神様に作って
神様は決まっているんだから
もう全知全能で万能で
あんた方は困る必要は何もないんだと
いったら何もないんだから
やることは
それは それだけはよしてくれと
すべて神様だと言ってもいいんだけど
人間は努力してくださいと一言だけ言ってほしいんですね
そうするとその教えが矛盾になりますが
やっぱりしょうがないんですね
ですから証拠ないものは仏教では認めませんから
そういう点ではあまり携わろうとしない
神の概念については
我々知っているのは
我々は頑張ったらその分が良くなるんだと
怠けたらその分が不幸になるんだということ
そういうことで
そこで話を終了しますけど
一応まとめます
完全主義というのは成り立たないことで
見方によってすべてそのままで完全だということは言えます
それは見方というのは無常の論理と
因果法則の教えに基づいて考えると
もうどんな現象でも100パーセントの
結果を出しているんだから
それ以上認めてはいけません
なぜそれ以上認めてなるかというと
人間の間違っている考え方で比べてみる
それは比べることもありえないことで
もし完璧主義になったと思ったら
その人は邪見を持っていて
すべてのものは無常で変化しているんだということを
否定しようとしている
ありえないことで
だから苦労だけになってしまっちゃうんだと
そういうぐらいのことで
我々は自分の力だけ精一杯出しちゃえば
いいんじゃないかなということと
それから世の中から我々はあなた完全になれ
あなた完全になれとは頼んではいけませんけど
仕事の場合はある仕事は完全にやってくれと
完璧に ある仕事は失敗したとしてもういいわ
もうやり直してもう一回やってくださいと
頼めばいいところもあるし
そういうふうに世の中のことは分析してみるという内容でした
どうもありがとうございます